Donald Trump absolutely dissembled
during the weekend Whitehouse
coronavirus press briefings and I
challenge you today to tell me what on
earth Donald Trump is talking about here
he actually seems ill in this video he's
not making any sense I cannot for the
life of me figure out what Donald Trump
is talking about but let's play it it's
the stuff of Horrors back to the scene
that he used to have which was look I
could tell you about and I'm not gonna
do it because I didn't want to bring it
up but I could tell you about events
that took place and I said things like
you'll never do that again or you'll
never do this again or I don't want to
make sure the events I don't want to
mention what you're supposed to be doing
because and you know one of them was so
horrible I said a certain industry will
be out of business never happen again
two weeks later was like nothing ever
happened
hopefully we get rid of this we have
tremendous talent up here and all over
including governor's that doesn't make
sense there is nothing there there is no
substance what Trump is talking about is
impossible to ascertain from what he is
saying look at a transcript of this it
doesn't mean anything
back to the scene which you used to have
which was look I could tell you about
and I'm not gonna do it because I didn't
want to bring it up but I could tell you
about events that took place and I said
things like you'll never do that again
or you'll never do this again or I don't
even want to mention the events I don't
want to mention what you're supposed to
be doing because and you know one of
them was so horrible I said a certain
industry will be out of business never
happen again two weeks later was like
nothing ever happened
hopefully we get rid of this we have
tremendous talent up here and all over
including governor's I don't know what
he's talking about this is not the way
someone who is of sound mind
communicates with people never mind on a
daily basis for hours day in and day out
where the reporters just have to sit
there and wait for it to end and ask
their next question here's another one
from
following day which again makes
absolutely no sense it's an unhinged and
wacky rant attacking the media as
thousands of Americans per day continue
to die
sources say you know what sources say
man sources say means they have nobody
and they make it up okay and they have a
few other type statements that mean the
same thing but sources say is the most
often used experiment us new york times
especially CNN fake news CNN they should
really be mandated and I mean mandated
to use a name if there's a source
username so there is Trump demanding
that journalistic convention around
sources sources of course an absolutely
critical element of journalism be thrown
out and all sources must be named you
can't have that you can't say sources
here you can't have an anonymous source
of course remember anonymous sources
typically are anonymous to the public
but the reporter knows who they are and
Trump just continuing to do this thing
where he attacks the basic conventions
of journalism and press freedom and then
Trump going on to talk about testing and
just how amazing and great everything is
and sort of promoting coronavirus tests
as if they're some new iPhone or
something like that that are just going
to crush the competition take a look I
don't believe the sources exist and I
try and tell this you know the beautiful
thing about doing these conferences is
that we have tremendous numbers of
viewers and I'm able to reach the
viewers without having to go through
fake news where they make a good story
into a bad story so with all of that
it's been an incredible period of time
we've done a fantastic job with the talk
of other nations the leaders of other
nations are calling us for help they're
calling us for equipment they're calling
us for testing capacities now with the
testing we are going further Deborah's
going to talk about that now with the
testing we have some other tests coming
up that are
going to be I think phenomenal I think
they're going to blow away everything as
soon as they come out and we're going to
get them out as soon as possible but I'd
like to ask dr. Burks to come up and say
a few words about where we've come how
far we've come and more importantly
where we're going from this point
because honestly it's it's quite amazing
thank you very much that's the President
of the United States if you can believe
it and then the testing thing we're
going to do a deeper dive into testing
tomorrow remember that the testing thing
is is now a way to scapegoat governors
for Donald Trump Trump has been bragging
for months about how all that's
happening with testing is because of him
and that we're testing the best and
we're testing the most and all of this
stuff now that Trump's talking about
reopening and numerous public health
officials are making clear we just don't
have the tests to reopen right now Trump
is very quickly shifting and talking
about hey listen these governors have to
test you know I mean we're doing what we
can here but the governor's really need
to do the testing the numbers right now
are we're testing about a hundred and
fifty thousand a day yesterday we tested
I think about a hundred and sixty-seven
thousand that's the most we've tested in
the day that needs to more than triple
to get us to a minimum for reopening we
need at least 500,000 tests a day that
we're doing not that are sitting
somewhere 500 thousand a day minimum one
roadmap says we need a million tests a
day to reopen one roadmap says we really
need 22 million a day to reopen which is
a crazy number but that would let you
test the whole country on a rolling
basis every two weeks
in any case Trump now starting to shift
blame on testing two governors and then
lastly here's Trump trying to humiliate
a reporter whose question he doesn't
like by interrupting and insisting the
guy tell him who he works for
and flippantly telling the guy yeah keep
reading your question of everything get
the American people don't understand why
you're unwilling to use the awesome
powers of your presidency to make
American companies manufacture PPE
also the testing equipment that you
implement the implement you were
recommendation enough but who are you in
our culture I was TM n recommendations
for me and what does tell immediate news
what my name is Doug Christian with talk
media news go ahead keep reading your
question so increasingly you're seeing
networks just not carrying the full
press briefings and it's tough because
new policy is announced that these press
briefings pretty often so here's my view
on it the Mike Pence part is worthless
pence goes up there he never announces
any new guidelines he praises Trump for
his leadership he lists the number of
you know masks that air bridge flights
are ordering or whatever I mean it's
it's absolutely meaningless so my policy
now it increasingly has been and now it
will be on a hard-and-fast basis I will
be muting the Mike Pence part it's
worthless the Trump part I do the best I
can to fact-check so that when Trump
lies about testing or this or that fact
I try to instantly rebut it so that at
least my audience understands how the
disinformation is being formulated and
then we have the portion where we hear
from doctors which is actually useful to
the extent that the doctors are telling
us the full truth
sadly dr. Burks is increasingly a vector
of mild disinformation as well very
clearly a placating Trump in ways that
go above and beyond the sort of mere
collegiality of doctor foul Chi dr.
Burks is actually becoming a perpetuator
of some of trumps disinformation and
then you have the question session which
I do actually find interesting to see
what reporters ask but that's where we
are right now in terms of the press
briefings and as you can see very
bizarre things are taking place at these
press briefings one of our sponsors is
cuts clothing giving you 15% off their
entire collection of super quality men's
t-shirts at david pakman.com slash cuts
that's cu TS the solid color t-shirt is
a core component of any guys wardrobe
certainly of mine which is all the more
reason why you should love the t-shirt
it's in your closet it impacts your
day-to-day life your typical poorly made
t-shirt scratches it shrinks the neck
stretches the color fades the whole
thing warps over time none of those
things happen with cuts clothing as soon
as I put one of their shirts on for the
first time I notice the comfort I notice
the quality I notice the look and the
fit and it's actually it's a noticeable
level of quality which would be
appropriate for something like going on
a date or going into the office if
you're watching on YouTube I am wearing
the classic Henley right now as you can
see go check out what cuts clothing has
to offer you will see and feel the
difference as soon as you put it on the
slogan is it's the only shirt worth
wearing and you will see why and you'll
get 15% off what's better than that by
going to david pakman.com slash cuts
that's david pakman.com slash c UTS